my guest tonight is an actress and a
comedian who stars with david spade
in the netflix film the wrong missy
and this film is hilarious she is
hilarious please welcome
i'm thrilled lauren lapkus lauren thanks
for doing this
thanks for having me um uh we'll talk
about your curtain later
[Laughter]
i don't know if you're in a puppet
theater or what's happening i'm just
hiding like tons of garbage
okay okay good it's nice you just draw a
curtain
um i uh i want to compliment you
i i don't i've known you for a long time
uh
and and we've worked together a little
bit and i've always thought you were
hilarious
and i watched your netflix film uh last
night
and i started to watch it by myself
and this movie starts from the get-go
like
the firing gun starts you show up i
think
30 seconds into the film and
i was laughing so hard that i paused it
and i went and found my wife and i said
you have to watch this with me
oh that money and so we went back to the
start of the movie
and you just kill it you are so funny in
this movie and i'm so happy for you
because i really do think this is one of
those
performances that's going to change
everything for you and i'm really happy
oh thank you so much that's so nice yeah
and i
i think and i think coming from me um
we all know the power lauren that i uh
wheeled in the business
this is huge for me yeah i'm like
spielberg in uh you know 87.
the equivalent because that's uh this
changes everything but no it was
so funny and you were so funny in so
many
different ways and i was remembering
that the first time i saw you was in a
little improv show for kids called story
pirates
yes yeah we got to do that together i
mean you didn't get to do it with me but
i got to do it with you and it was very
exciting
it's this theater company in new york
and la that takes stories written by
children
and adapts them into sketches and songs
and it's really fun and like really high
quality kids entertainment
um and i used to be in that theater
company in new york and la and we did a
show at the guffin and we had you as our
celebrity guest and it was so
fun i mean i think you sang a song about
wetting your pants which
sounds like me that's an old gershwin
classic
by the way uh the wrong missy i
think is one of the most popular films
on netflix
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's
it's this is a big deal for you yeah
this is
through adam sandler's production
company this film and adam sandler's the
executive producer
and uh adam's wife is in the film and
then i notice
and and she does a great job but then i
notice there's this really
there's this moment where your character
loses it can be incredibly foul-mouthed
can be
foul in all these different ways it's
hilarious but there's this moment where
you're yelling at these kids
when you show up at this resort in
hawaii and i noticed that the kids are
adam's kids
and you're being really and i'm like was
adam on set when that happened
he was there that day and it was kind of
like
it was interesting because i think for a
little like a little bit i felt more
pressure because he was there of course
and like
i you know i like him i admire him and
i'm like oh i have to like perform on
front of him but then i also have to
scream at his kids
and um he just told me to go harder he
was like just scream just swear at them
just go like just come in hot and i was
like okay
and and they liked it they were they
were great but oh no i'm sure they got
it but do you
do you sense in a weird way that adam
was
using you to vent anger
yeah that was really clear actually and
that maybe possibly that was the reason
the whole movie
existed just to have that one scene
there's a part in the movie uh where
you get fish chum just chopped up fish
parts thrown in your face and it looks
really disgusting and they sell it
really well and i thought what
i'm just hoping that that was plastic
and fake and not real
i have to tell you it was 100 real um
because
well actually it was supposed to be fake
but then the prop guy told me like the
day before
like he pulled me aside and he was like
hey um
that that fish i was supposed to get
this like fake fish and it didn't arrive
in time and so i'm like
i'm gonna use real fish and i was like
yeah cool that's funny
he's like no i'm like i'm dipping it in
lemon and i'm trying to make it smell
good
and i'm taking all the bones out but
it's going to be real and i was like
okay like it's just like i feel like i
can't i can't argue against that i just
have to go with that
and so then they're just dumping fish in
my you know like rob schneider and uh
you know stunt man are just throwing
actual fish guts in my face and hair and
then
people have to de-bone me for like an
hour on the boat
and then we do it again okay
i'm gonna say this on your behalf um
that doesn't happen to you again
i understand that you had to do this to
to in this movie but i think
after this movie that's done you know
maybe maybe now i can i can stand up for
myself and
just i don't know i don't know what
you're supposed to do in that situation
though i mean just like say to
make it all cgi or something i don't
know i'll tell you that
i've been have doing the show for
whatever
you know 27 years or something and i've
gotten to the point where i'll [ __ ]
about it and be passive-aggressive
yeah we're like okay well we just won't
do it i'll go like no no
it's fine and then i put on you know a
woman's thong and they dropped me
into liquid diarrhea i think i missed
that episode
that's such a good episode
[Laughter]
it was uh man it was a theme episode it
was okay
your personal perversions oh is that my
oh that's yeah that's my perversion yeah
let me ask you i know that you've been
um
you know i'm a bit in the podcast world
and you've been doing it for a long time
very successfully
and um i know you do this podcast with
nicole byer
i'm a big fan of hers as well and so the
idea of working together
is fantastic and the the podcast is
called newcomers
can you tell me what does newcomers mean
what's that theme for the podcast cause
it sounds interesting
yeah so each season we're gonna watch
something we've never seen before
and the first season is all about star
wars and neither of us had ever seen
i mean any of it we barely knew anything
going in
and we've now seen all of it and
i feel very informed and i feel ready to
move on
what a ringing endorsement
universe well i mean there's so much and
like
one of the things that i think about
with this with going through this
podcast is like
everybody who's a huge fan of star wars
you get like 10 years between each movie
basically
so you're really excited you're happy
that it's like really long like there's
so much to like figure out and dissect
and like new technology
and we're just watching it all in a span
of a few months so like every week i'm
watching
another star wars movie or like a series
or like an ewok movie which is a
spin-off that like is crazy and we're
just spending so much time like watching
these movies talking about them
dissecting them
we have on guests who are really
passionate about it so it helps to
balance because we're usually confused
or like mad about something
but it's been really fun i'm curious did
you have a favorite character
after watching all of it not knowing
anything and then watching all of the
star wars catalog did you come away with
like okay this is my obsession
yeah i have a couple well nicole's is
jar jar binks so i think that's amazing
because like people were really upset
about jar jar back in the day
but um i love porgs i love baboo frick
and i like i can't believe i'm saying
this but this is like really weird for
me
um i love baboo frick and i love um
i like yoda so yeah wow really going on
a limb with yoda
well you have to pick one classic you
mentioned
ewoks i remember being very irritated by
ewoks when they showed up in the star
wars franchise yeah i love them i think
they're so
cute and funny and they're so great
there is you have to google this there's
a today show clip with al roker where
there are ewoks
and they're they're i don't know why
they're there i guess it's like just an
episode where that was connected somehow
but they start like grinding on him and
like grinding on the floor and doing
like the moonwalk and it's
amazing you know i heard that this clip
existed
and we have it ready and i know okay i
don't want to disappoint our viewers so
let's take a look at the ewoks on the
today show
uh just quick look decorative icing and
then you're just gonna put some blood
ooh
gushing moonwalking apparently you need
a couple of these guys
and that was a day where there was
really serious news
be great if there was just an
international incredibly big
you know that was that was the tragedy
and then like the
power plant blew up in russia and they
were like we're gonna get to that
but first ewok's humping dry humping al
roker
season two okay you did star wars what's
season two gonna be
it's gonna be lord of the rings you've
never watched those
no and do you know them
i actually i have to say i've watched
them
because over the years um i
had you know when they were making those
movies we
had all the people that were in the
movies come on the show about them so i
would watch the movies
and i really liked them but
half the time i don't know what anyone's
talking about i think that's going to be
a big problem for us because we can't
keep track of storylines or names
like at all in star wars and i've heard
that there are more names and they all
have nicknames
in lord of the rings and every movie is
three and a half hours which is longer
than star wars so
i'm feeling nervous they're beautiful
films
and the performances are really great
and i find them to be really majestic
and they take you away so in all those
reasons it's great but then there's a
lot of
we must go to build a shire and find
proud drachmann
and then he'll take us to mordom
and i don't know what they're talking
about can you just reenact them for us
and just like have that be with the
podcast yeah
there's just so many different shires
and places and then there are
elves that don't like everyone's sort of
racist towards each other like elves
don't like you know
there's always these biases and and you
think like why do elves not like
you know whatever gnomes and why do
gnomes hate trolls and white of fairies
yeah
just it's craziness but um
you don't have to always know what's
going on well that's good
because i just won't i'm sure i i try to
like i pay very close
attention and sometimes i even record
myself watching the movie as like a
watch along that people can listen to
so it helps me like focus and i'm like
who's that guy and then my husband will
explain something
and i'll still then go and go into the
podcast and have no idea what i watch
like it's it's very hard for it to stay
in here
right right well uh it's not just you
it's just
i'm constantly having trouble uh knowing
what's happening in a movie even simple
movies
uh wizard of oz they're literally
following a yellow brick road and i'm
like what's happening
they're saying no they're what are you
talking about my children are saying
calm down this is what
they're still on the yellow brick road
and the witch is trying to stop them and
other than that it's pretty linear
why um we have a clip here from the
wrong missy
okay and i believe i don't want to give
too much away but
uh david spade thinks that he has
invited someone else
on a romantic getaway uh but because of
a miscommunication
uh texting he's invited you
you show up and i think this is the
scene we're gonna see is that correct
yeah i don't know you don't know and you
don't care do you
you've changed with your you're not the
lauren latkes i met back in the day
you've got your
curtain now and your striped shirt
and your blue microphone think you're
all that and a bag of chips
well anyway that's the clip
it's so great to see you
you smell so good what is that that's
soap
sorry i'm a little sweaty i had a whole
tsa pat down
guess i'm too sexy no i had a i had
sheila
in my purse but i got away with it
because i told him it was a service
knife
so don't worry you're protected
what are you doing here what are we
doing here
what are you doing here what are you
doing here yeah
are these for me those aren't you got me
roses
that is so sweet mmm i want to
motorboat them
i've never flown first class this is
crazy
wait what's in this bag what in the
world like free stuff oh my god
i didn't have any of this deodorant
that's perfect
um all right well i'm gonna let you go i
know you have i really do think you have
a puppet show to do
i don't really think about that energy
that this gives off but you're totally i
don't know what it is
or you're gonna be displaying cosmetics
i should do something from home like a
commercial yeah
um all right we'll stay well and um
and i really do hope to see you soon
here at largo yeah this is
one of the last things i did live was a
show here at largo
with like sandler and apatow and oh wow
and it was so much fun and i think a
couple of days later
everything shut down it's crazy yeah
literally the
the day things were shutting down i i
did who wants to be a millionaire i got
to like be a contestant
and it was the most exciting day of my
life and then we like went back home and
everything was shut down we couldn't
tell anyone it was like the weirdest
most dystopic feeling
is odd yeah yeah did you did you win
anything i won five hundred thousand
dollars for charity
charity yeah oh
i would love it do you want to know the
question that i i would actually wanted
to quiz you on this because i thought
you would know the answer to this
i may not but go ahead okay this was the
question that i had to get to get the
five hundred thousand dollars
and i had to call my dad as my lifeline
and he helped me but
okay six u.s presidents
share the same first name john
james george william which
there are six presidents that have that
one name
uh it's not william can i hear him again
john james george william
wow george washington george bush
man that's a really good question it's
really hard
i don't know anything about president so
i was like totally screwed yeah i do i
just know that there's a lot of george's
and then there's james madison james
polk
james uh man
now you're you're just want to go and
now no i want you to guess it
okay can i write these down george i'm a
i'm eliminating uh william george
and i think i'm wise to do that hello
you're correct you're correct
george james and what's the other one um
george james john
john adams john f kennedy
there's james garfield there's a lot of
j
there's james polk there's
do you want a hint yeah there's like a
nickname
associated with one of the names that
also makes
like there are more presidents use a
nickname as well well
yeah because i i think it's going to be
james because
that's i just think it has to be james
because it can be jimmy it could be
james it could be jim yeah so that's
what it is that's correct
but it was so tense my dad i called my
dad and he said john and then we were
just sitting there for like 10 seconds
and i was like are you sure
and then he was like james james james
and i get hung up on him
and then i had to sit there for 10
minutes and weigh whether or not i trust
my dad
like it was just like crazy you know
what i wish i wish i had been on that
show and i wish i had
answered that correctly i think i would
have answered that correctly and then
i wish that i had won and i've been
really excited and then i wish that
on camera they had reminded me that the
money goes to charity
and i wish everyone could have seen my
face fall
[Laughter]
and then me start to kind of ask like
well i mean yes i imagine some ghost
attorney
and then see me getting into it with the
executive producers as the credits come
down
anyway thank you so much thank you
everyone check out the wrong missy
uh you know it's during these times
right now a movie this funny
is the perfect cure and uh
and i hope to see you soon in in better
circumstances
me too thanks so much for having me no
problem thank you